oh look
another glorious morning
makes me sick
hocus pocus
this walt disney pictures film was a
huge flop at the box office in 1993 but
has since become a beloved cult classic
rewashed by millions every halloween
season
but how and why did hocus pocus go from
such a disaster to a must-watch seasonal
movie
welcome back everyone to stream in the
galaxy my name is rocket riley and today
we're going to be talking about the 1993
disney film hocus pocus and why people
seem to be so obsessed with it but
before we get started if you're new to
the channel please hit the subscribe
button and click the bell icon to be
notified when we upload a new video
at its initial release in july of 1993
hocus pocus was a flop at the box office
earning only 39 million dollars that's
right the halloween themed movie was
released in july only a month after the
smash hit jurassic park
because of a weak marketing campaign
poor critic reviews and the marginal
desire for a halloween movie during the
summer hocus pocus did not do so well
now however the film has made waves in
popularity as it's basically been played
on repeat for two decades on freeform
and abc family during the month of
october
it's these continual reruns which
initially set off the hocus pocus craze
kids and even adults would watch the
movie once or maybe four times every
year during the abc family 31 nights of
halloween
now 20 years later these kids have grown
up and built a great sense of nostalgia
for the film because they've come to
either have a strong association between
hocus pocus and their fond halloween
memories or because it's one of their
yearly must-do rituals
but where does this sense of nostalgia
come from the short answer
the nostalgia really comes from people
remembering what it felt like to be a
child watching the sanderson sisters
perform i put a spell on you during the
halloween season it makes us feel
connected not only to a time long past
but to everyone else who shares those
memories with us
it likely all started due to the fact
that many parents only allowed their
kids to watch three different halloween
themed movies hocus pocus halloween town
and the nightmare before christmas
all of these movies have strong cult
followings stemming from the same basic
principles that building an association
between a movie and a certain time of
year will improve the movie's yearly
rewatch ability and that creating a
strong sense of nostalgia will generate
better long-term profits
now there are some more specific
elements of the film which help
contribute to our obsession with hocus
pocus
first of all while it's not too scary
for a child hearing the phrase it's all
just a bunch of hocus pocus does sort of
send shivers down your spine when you
know it's not just hocus pocus also who
doesn't love our favorite feline friend
thackery binks you know banks i'll
always take care of you
my children will take care of you too
and their children after that
and theirs after that
the way the movie related to the kids
watching was also done in a way that
only disney movies did at the time
calling school a prison for children
just reassured millions of kids that
they were right and that adults were the
ones who were wrong
also don't forget that max had basically
the coolest room in the world at the top
of their colonial salem massachusetts
home
the movie also introduced tons of new
words to our vocabularies like virgin
yabbos and many more
wedge
trollop
you
bucktooth
[Applause]
mostly the general cheesiness and crazy
hijinks that we all secretly wish to be
a part of just set us in the halloween
mood whether it be the iconic costumes
and looks of the sanderson sisters or
the wonderfully terrible cgi used
throughout the film every bit of hocus
pocus drives the sense of nostalgia
deeper making those warm fuzzy feelings
bubble back up to the surface
hocus pocus truly is worthy of the
obsession so many people hold for it
well that's going to be everything from
us today on hocus pocus if you enjoyed
the video please hit the like button and
don't forget to subscribe for more great
content what's your favorite hocus-pocus
memory drop in the comment section below
from everyone here at stream in the
galaxy we hope you have a great day and
thanks for watching
you